[Música]
y volvemos con más información económica
internacional y para ello nos vuelve a
acompañar en el estudio Juan Pablo
lucumi bienvenido de nuevo acá estamos
una vez más y abrimos con este dato no
que va a mover los mercados
internacionales que ya lo está haciendo
Y es el dato del aumento de las tasas de
interés por el Banco Central europeo
luego de que ayer la reserva Federal de
Estados Unidos haya tomado También la
misma decisión respecto a las tasas de
referencia para los detalles vamos a
conectar con nuestra corresponsal en
Bruselas y las Esther Herrera Esther
Cuál fue la decisión del Banco Central
europeo
Hola buenos días El Banco Central
europeo ha decidido subir con 0 cinco
puntos los tipos de interés se trata de
una subida menor de lo que se ha
producido en los últimos meses como
comentaba sigue así la Estela de la
reserva Federal de Estados Unidos
recordemos que desde diciembre las
subidas del Banco Central europeo de
tipos había sido hasta ahora de medio
punto se relaja así a 0,25 puntos con
esta decisión aún así ahora mismo la
tasa se encuentra en un
3,75% es la Cota más alta desde la
crisis financiera desde 2008 lo que por
lo tanto nunca había estado durante en
15 años nunca había estado tan alta el
precio del dinero en la eurozona del
frenazo en gran parte se debe a que la
inflación se está moderando sobre todo
la inflación subyacente la que no tiene
encuentra en la que no tiene en cuenta
los alimentos frescos ni tampoco la
energía aún así esta inflación sigue
siendo muy alta en la eurozona se sitúa
en un 7% y recordemos
que el objetivo del Banco Central
europeo es de mantenerla en el 2%, por
ello el Banco Central europeo ya ha
avanzado que seguirá aumentando los
tipos aunque no avanza cómo lo hará esto
es Muchas gracias por descifrarnos esta
actualidad económica desde la capital
Europea
y Juan Pablo nos trae los indicadores un
día más así es porque este tema también
ha pues afectado Los indicadores a las
13 horas de gmt los tres principales
indicadores presentaban pérdidas el
Frankfurt una caída del 0,63% el
indicador de Londres un 0,73% y el
indicador de París un
0,99% en nuestra región las bolsas
cerraron en terreno mixto Chile Colombia
tuvieron leves ganancias mientras
Argentina Tuvo una profunda pérdida del
2,58% Y si nos vamos a Estados Unidos
con su apertura los tres principales
indicadores también tuvieron leves
pérdidas todo esto con los datos de las
tasas de interés cuanto a la reserva
federal y el Banco Central europeo Juan
Pablo y rápidamente la noticia de que el
Banco Central le dijo a Brasil cuándo
tendría que invertir para lograr sus
metas climáticas Así es estamos hablando
del Banco Mundial la entidad hizo las
estimaciones correspondientes y dijo que
la primera economía de América Latina
debe invertir el 0,8% de su producto
interno bruto hasta 2030 si quiere
lograr los objetivos climáticos que se
ha trazado ahora esta inversión del 0,8%
lastimó el Banco Mundial para el tramo
de final de década mientras que le dijo
que la inversión debía ser de por lo
menos el 1,2% si se evalúan las metas
del tramo 2022-2050 en el cual ellos
tienen otros objetivos Así que es una
inversión bastante grande de su pib
veremos y cerramos con la cifra del día
es un millón de turistas ha recibido
Cuba en lo que va del 2023 en medio de
una jornada de recuperación económica
según informó el Ministerio del turismo
de ese país un destino que tengo muchas
ganas de visitas Juan Pablo Muchas
gracias por todo este repaso mañana con
mucho más de economía